Herkes güel
[Müzik]
bir i cdi anlamda
uğraşıyorum çok da merak ediyorum bu
öğretmenliğin daha iyisi daha güzeli
daha verimlisi daha
faydalısı daha iyi öğrenme iyi
öğrenme bugünkü konu
kesişme kesişme bir şeyle tanışıyorsun
bir kitap okuyorsun Bir Film izliyorsun
biriyle konuşuyorsun bir şey oluyor ve
bir şey
değiyor
öğet
ğ
geriyor değişim bir
farkındalık oluş haline geliyor Kaf ve
onun üzerinden bir değişim
gerçekleşiyor öğreniyoruz çok
uğraştım öğrenilir
uğraştım çok iyi öğrenen çocuklarla
[Müzik]
çalıştım
farkındalık başka bir bakış açısına
geç parmaği Paradigma yenilenmesi gi bir
süre bunun olmesi iin
ğ gerçekleşmesi lazım
çünkü etmiyor Bazen bireyle
kesişiyoruz o bize bir farkındalık
yaratıyor bir cümle bir an bir ifade bir
değişim bir şey yaratıyor Bunların hepsi
çok güzel şeyler öğretmenliği çok
seviyordum İstanbul matematiği bitirdim
şu an Vefa lisesiz şurada hemen Fen
Fakültesi 1 kilometre falandır herhalde
diye tahmin
ediyorum Biraz böyle zorlanan bir
öğrenciydim biraz böyle Haylaz mı
diyeyim
biraz böle yaramaz belki
Yani kazanmıştım annem de bana demişti
ki Kazan ne istersen yaparsın sonra ben
de tamam dedim dosyası kazand ii o zam
dönem ii birsas Kazas çok güzel
ok Ondan sonra biraz böyle derslerle o
kadar
ilgilenmedim iane kaldım kırıklar
geldi sonra sistem Vardı bizim
zamanımızda belki burada hocalarımızdan
falan bilenlerden vardır matematikten
kald aldım Sonra bir daha kaldım falan
Eee üniversite tercih sırasında
matematiği seviyordum yani böyle o
sayıları hareket ettirmek anlamak
kavramak hoşuma gidiyordu Ben de
matematikle ilgili istatistikle ilgili
bölümler yazdım İstanbul matematiği
kazandım benim Kafamdaki
matematikle İstanbul Fen Fakültesi
Matematik
arasında bayağı bir fark varmış İşte
girdik
[Müzik]
giz
yer gidiyorsunuz işte fen fakültes içeri
giriyorsunuz merdivenlerden çıkıyorsunuz
bir 50 metrelik bir koridor var K Katar
öğren işleri var üniversite sını 4 tane
ders analiz varik analiz var soyut
bilgisayar dersi vardı gba Onlar aldım
prr yaım ki Kay sağ tar ders çalış
program var ii ded K program
Oray anizi büyü pesi gün 9 öen son so
dersi var
falanları yan tarafda benden büyük biri
var 4 sınıfta olduğunu hissediyorum
çünkü 4 sınıf derslerine
bakıyor yani Konuş Mer Edi yi gelmi
insanlarla tanak
istiyorum
[Müzik]
is dersine dikkat et dedi O dedi biraz
sıkıntı bir ders Allah Allah ya konuya
bak yani Ben ne bileyim başka bir şey
konuşuruz falan diye düşünürken
tamam teşekkür Edim kazanıp geld D Neyse
çıkıyorsunuz Çocuklar arkadaşlar
üniversite iinde geziyorsunuz böyle
kafanıza yatan insan arıyorsunuz Böyle
arkadaşlık etmek istiyorsun insanlarla
doğal ve normal bir süreç olarak çıktım
işte biraz gezerken falan filan
Gaziantepli Altan diye hoş bir adam
buldum iyi adam konuşuyoruz muhabbet
ediyoruz falan filan beraber
yki Sinem
gideriz anlarımızı paylaşır maç
Yar güzel bir adam ii bir adaman berer
Sabahları buluşuyoruz ama daha çok
yeniyiz
Yani çz yani oaman çi yi
geli öğce anlamın
geli
mat diye bir yer varki buranın katı
falan ön tarafta tane böyle blok var
arka tarafta tane blok var Biz sağ arka
blokta Altan oturuyoruz yeni gelmişiz
ama dah Yani bir kere tuvalete gitmişiz
bir kere kantine gitmişiz çay ve simit
almışız falan çekiniyoruz ama tanışmak
da istiyoruz
insanlarla oturuyoruz bizim arkamızda
tane boşluk var ondan sonra tane kız
var
[Müzik]
h kızlardan bir tanesi döndü dedi ki
silginiz var mıa dedim konu Buyurun
dedim silgim var silgiyi uzattım verdim
kız döndü bana dedi ki siz Dedi Kaçıncı
sınıfsın şimdi o kadar saçma bir soru ki
yani 1 sınıf derse biz de 1 Siz yani
Hani bana dese ki İstanbul'da nerede
oturuyorsun anlamlı bir soru işte
Anadolu'dan mı geldin İstanbul'dan mı
kazandın anlamlı bir soru bana dese ki
tramvayla mı geldin Otobüsle mi geldin
Yürüyerek mi geldin anlamlı bir soru
bana dese ki ailen yaşıyorsun Yurtta mı
yaşıyorsun işte arkadaşlarınla eve mi
çıktın yine anlamlı bir soru bana diyor
ki siz diyor Kaç sınıf öğrenciniz diyor
Neyse dedi Biz 1 sınıf öğrencisiyiz kız
çok şaşırdı nasıl yani dedi Siz dedi 1
sınıf öğrencisi misiniz dedi Evet ded
biz 1 sınıf öğrencisiyiz Siz dedim kaç
sınıf öğrenciniz kız döndü dedi ki ben
dedi 2
sınıfım arkadaşım dedi 3
sınıf dedim Nasıl yani 1 sınıf dersi ve
falan dedim ön taraftan sakallı bir
çocuk döndü böyle arkasına Altan da bana
baktı Dedi ki siz Dedi gerçekten 1
sınıflı
sınız dedim bir şey söyleyeceğim ben
size Evet dedim 1 sınıf dersinde biz 1
sınıfız yani burada dedi garip olan biz
miyiz Durdu durdu Siz de bir kaçıncı
sınıfınız ben dedi 4
sınıfım sonra döndü dedi ki İlk seferde
geçeceğini mi sanıyorsunuz
kazanıp geldim başka da diyecek bir şey
yok zaten Neyse arkadaşlar alanla
birlikte analiz birden
kaldık yı tekrarın aldık yine kaldık
sonan ki K Ben gidiyorum nereye oğum Ben
gidiyorum abi üniversite sınavına bir
daha gireceğim 3 sınıftan bıraktı Yıldız
teke GTİ yıld grafik tasarım bölüm okudu
oradan mezun oldu fal Ben azimle devam
etmeye çalışıyorum yani Yol uzun ama
yani böyle
[Müzik]
50 bahsediyorum 144 kuralına Ben
takılmadım yani 1 sınıf derslerim
bittiği için 4 sınıftan ders alabilir
duruma geliyorsun İstanbul matematik
işte 96'da girmişim yıl 2000 olmuş ben
14E takılmamış o kadar büyük bir Prestij
ki size anlatamam yani 144'e takılmamış
falan hani nam hocam Tab bir sürü şey
anlatıyor Bizim presti ufak hocamın
anlattıklarına sonuna kadar saygı
duyuyoruz Bizim ufak ama prestijli yani
yürk
takık falan geziyoruz güzel birum bizim
[Müzik]
adım 4 sınıftayım dersler yarısı duruyor
3ün tamamı duruyor 4 ders alacağım
falan yıllar iç bce varı gelmiş ama
sce
merler Program
aldım yerini
[Müzik]
bili gittiğim zaman 4 sınıf derslerine
bakıyorum biri geldi benim yanıma 1
sınıf dersine bakıyor yani 4 yıl önce
yaşadığımız Şeyin
aynısı şimdi anlatsam bir türlü
anlatmasam bir
türlü heyecanlı ama görüyorsun yani
motivasyonu da bozmak istemiyorsun ama
bir de işin vebali var yani bir şeyleri
söyleme ihtiyacın yardım etme
ihtiyacın dedim bir şey söyleyeceğim
sana Efendim dedim sen dedim Kaçıncı
sınıf öğrencisin ben dedi 1 sınıf
öğrencisiyim ya dedim bu dediğimi ne
kadar anlayacaksın bilmiyorum ama dedim
nedir dedim Dedim bu analiz 1E dikkat et
dedim Yani bu biraz sakat bir ders Ben
kazanıp geldik dedi tamam dedik Eyvallah
dedik şey demedik gitti Bir daha da
hayatım boyunca görmedim çocuklar yıllar
içerisinde bitirdim Ben İstanbul
matematiği 7 yıl
sürdü sonra matematikçi olduğum için
sayı
ünit
[Müzik]
mat
eşit aık öğrencisi benim alesim yaklaş
yok yani en yakınd 20 puan falan öndeyim
çok ii bir
pozisy ama
tektim üniversiteyi 7 yılda bitirmiş
olmak Yani şimdi mülakata gireceğiz
hocalarla
hocalu insan kaynakçı olmak isunu ğen
isun onu çalıştım bunu çalıştım falan
filan Geç hocanın karşısına Merhaba
merhaba falan filan erkek olan Hoca
döndü D ki Koray Hocam dedi sana bir şey
soracağım dedi buun Hocam dedi İstanbul
matematiği kaç yılda bitirdin dedi ya
bismillah yani ya dakika bir gol bir
yani Hani bana dese ki bu alesi yapmayı
nasıl başardın falan anlatacağım bana
dese ki şu nasıl onu anlatacağım falan
filan neden insan kaynakçı olmak
istiyorsun neden şurada gelişmek
istiyorsun anlatacağım ama bana dedi ki
İstanbul bu matematiği kaç yılda
bitirdin işte Hocam falan Oğlum kaç
yılda bitirdin dedi işte hocam Eee falan
Koray dedi Efendim hocam dedim kaç yılda
bitird
dedi hocam dedim bizim bölüm biraz zor
Ben dedim orayı 7 yılda bitirdim
Kafamdaki mantıkla beni almayacak yüksek
lisansa Çünkü 7 yılda üniversite
bitirmiş diye bakıyor diye bekliyordum
Hoca döndü dedi ki iyi Tebrik ediyorum
seni bitirmişsin dedi ben orada dedi Bir
yıl okudum dedi bitmeyeceğini anladım
dedi Ondan sonra işletme tarafına geçtim
dedi bitirdim dedim Seni tebrik ediyorum
ben seni yüksek lisansa alırım dedi
mesela o da benim adıma bir kırılım
noktasıydı bir kesişme
noktasıydı sonrasında Eee daha iyi
öğretmen nasıl olurum daha çok şey nasıl
yaparım daha çok katkı nasıl sağlarım
diye uğraşmaya başladım merak ettim daha
çok yardım etmeye çalıştım
Eee çocuklar yapamıyordu ben de onlara
yardım etmeyi seviyordum yani o
yapamıyor onu
Yani olmuyor yani yapamıyor Onu
görüyorsun kıyamıyorsun ona yardım etme
Güdüm bir artıyor falan daha iyi öğrete
lazım Daha Ç danışmanlıklar almaya
başladım eğitimler almaya başladım
internetten konu anlatımları kitaplar
okuyorum Daha iyi öğretmen olmam lazım
daha iyi öğretmen olmam lazım daha iyi
öğretmen olmam lazım daha iyi öğretmen
olmam lazım sürekli bir kendimi
geliştirme aray çaba içerisindeyim nasıl
daha iyi öğretirim dah ii öğrenir ne
yapars daha akında kalır yaps
dah
dah ii hareket etbir ne yaparsam daha
uzun süre onu kullanabilir durumda kalır
hangi davranışları geliştirir o dah iyi
yapar duruma gelir Tabi ki zekaya çok
inanıyorum ama ana meselenin kendi
kafamda çalışmak olduğuna inanıyorum
zeka güzel bir şey ama çala çala ben ona
bunu öğretirim mantığım var sonrasında
beraber çalıştığım Çok sevgili bir hocam
[Müzik]
varız
küçük bir yer kurduk orada öğrenci
hazırlıyoruz yaptıracağım Olmadı bir
daha yaptıracağım Olmadı bir daha
yaptıracağım Yine olmadı bir daha
yaptıracağım Yine olmadı bir dah
yaptığım bir daha olmadı Ben belli bir
süre sonra bir
baktım ben günde 17 saat ders
anlatıyorum her sabah saat 7'de
giriyorum gece 12'ye kadar
hiçi
dah 7 günü atıyorum yasal çalışma 180
saat falan Ben ayda 500 saat çalışıyorum
ben ona bunu öğreteceğim diye O çocuk
geliyor Ona öğretmeye çalışıyorum öbür
çocuk geliyor Ona öğretmeye çalışıyorum
öbür çocuk geliyor Ona öğretmeye
çalışıyorum Oradan iyi çalıştık güzel
çalıştık i çocuklar değişip değişip
geliyorlar falan filan iyi çalışınca
oradan Türkiye birisi çıktı Türkiye
birisi çıkınca daha çok talep geldi
falan ne yaparız diye düşündük daha
büyük bir yere geçelim istedik işte
[Müzik]
dah benle Tamam dedi gitti baktı şöyle
yaparız K böyle yaparız K şöyle yaparız
gerekirse dedi Bir yıl dedi Sen de evine
para götürmez Ben de ev para götür bu
işi yaparız Ben senin hakkını vereceğim
biliyorum dedi hakkını vereceğini bir
sorun yok ama dedi yapalım şu işi Hadi
dedim
yapalım girdik öğrenci geliyor
çalıştırıyoruz öğrenci geliyor
çalıştırıyoruz g dedi ki kayi yayın
kuralım bizim işimiz bu değiliz soru bı
nıce bilmiyoruz kiir dağ Ne para biliriz
bilmiyoruz yani Yok
yapacağız Nasıl yapacağız yapacağız
diyorum sana
dedi dedim Anak yapayım ben de o zaman
Falan filan neyse sen şunu üretirsin sen
şunu üretirsin falan filan bana dedi ki
bir dağıtım şirketi var dedi kalk dedi
Oraya git adamla bir görüş pazarlama
müdürünü bul dedi oranın gittim
pazarlama müdürünü buldum dedim biz
böyle bir küçük Butik bir yeriz soru
bankası üretmek istiyoruz kaliteli güzel
sorular falan filan
[Müzik]
eş görme bir adamla Kın şöyle merakı ble
merak ğ istiyoruz niyetli
[Müzik]
fanlar
ezdi
Uz Allah
nea ağ kaldıra sorun yoken ymak
istiyorum başladık
çalışm özellikleri nelerdir hangi
hareketi yaparsanız daha iyi
öğrenirsiniz sınav neden vardır nasıl
yapılır diye çeşitli konuşmalar yapmaya
başladım ben yaptıkça Anadolu'dan davet
geliyor Ben yaptıkça Anadolu'dan davet
geliyor 48 ilde 200.000 civarı öğrenciye
konuşma yaptım binden fazla okula girip
çıktım Hatay'a da gittim Rize'ye de
gittim Adana'ya Urfa'ya Diyarbakır'a
Trabzon'a Samsun'a bir sürü yere gittim
çocuklara konuşma yapıyorum
Arka taraftaki mantığımız da şu 17 saat
çalışırken bir tane çocuk var
zorm bir
dah bir
bir bir
h az CD Hocam çok
güz CD olsun
[Müzik]
Tamar gidiyordum 4 okulda konuşuyordum
Cuma günü İzmir'e gidiyordum 4 okulda
konuşuyordum Cumartesi pazara dershanede
çalışıyordum daha çok Nasıl yaparız Daha
iyi nasıl yaparız yaparız yaparız
yaparız yaparız yaparız
derken şimdi gittiğim
okullarda belli bir süre sonra daha çok
gözlem yapmaya başlıyorsun benim adıma
yine bir kesişim noktası bir değişim
oluşmaya başladı Çünkü ben kendi kafamda
bir şey var gidiyorum Onu çocuklara
anlatıyorum bir şey söylüyorlar Bazen
anlıyorum bazen anlamıyorum bazen
alıyorum bazen
almıyorum söyledim ki Ben Bu İnsanları
daha çok
dinlemeliyim Ben öğretmenim onlar da
öğretmen ben bu hareketi yapınca
inanılmaz iyi Öğretmenlerle tanışmaya
başladım Ben kendi kafama göre iyi bir
öğretmendim adamın yaptıklarını
gördükten
sonra ben kendi öğretmenliğimi
sorguladım dedim Koray
500.000 fırın daha ekmek yemen
lazım akıllılara zarar öğretmenler var o
kadar iyi o kadar muhteşem o kadar canlı
o kadar
değiştirebilen o kadar
inovatif inovasyon değişim farkındalık
farklılık hamle
yapabilme Trabzon'da bir sü okula
giriyoruz akş
kadar takıyoruz bir 50 ş dedim buna
dikkat edin bak şu videoyu izleyin
burada çocuk böyle yapıyor Şurada şöyle
yapıyor burada böyle yapıyor anlatıyoruz
bir okula girdim işte sağ tarafta
Atatürk köşesi var sol tarafta Yangı
köşesi var ya da tam
tersi yukarıda iki tane bisiklet var
bisikleti oraya böyle vidalam
falan garip geldi
bana Neyse gitti konuşma yaptık okul
müdürü dedi ki Kay hocam çay içelim mi D
dedim mutlaka çay içelim Ben de merak
ediyorum sizle tanışmak istiyorum hocam
dedi olur dedi Oturduk hocam dedim bir
şey soracağım size evet dedi dedim o
bisikletler nedir Yani ben dedim
Anlayamadım merak ettim dedi kor Hocam
dedi kırtasiye dedi okula dedi kitap
satmak istiyordu Ben de ona dedim ki
dedi bana iki tane bisiklet hediye
edersen ben senin okula satış yapmana
izin vereceğim Ne yaptın dedim had
görevliye dedim ki dedi bisikletleri
Tabana yap
kitle bayrak tör çocukları konuşuyor
diyor ki çocuklar diyor
başarısını en çok artırana bisiklet
hediye edeceğim diyor bakın en iyisine
demiyor adam başarısını en çok artırana
bisiklet hediye edeceğim diyor Ne
yapıyorsun hocam diyorum bazen bakıyorum
diyor çocuklarda bir yavaşlama oluyor
diyor görevliye söylüyorum bisikletleri
söktürüyor diyor bahçede ikişer tur attı
hepsi motive oluyor diyor hepsi daha çok
yapmaya çalışıyor diyor Adana'da bir
okul müdürü
girdik çok eski bir
okul adam yaptıklarını bir anlatmaya
başladı
öğrencilerle çocuklarla futbol takımları
kurmuş çocukların zor hayatlarını
değiştirmeye çalışmış onları hareket
ettirmeye çalışmış aileleriyle görüşmüş
akşam başlarında kalmış şunu yapmış bunu
yapmış orada o olmuş Onun parasını o
vermiş öbürünü o yapmış falan filan 15
dakika
sonra çıkamıyorsun da öyle bir enteresan
güzel anlatıyor ki adam ben ağlamaya
başladım adamın
karşısında böyle İşi gücü bırakıp adamın
elini öpesim geliyor Bir daha yap Bir
daha yap Bir şey daha yap Bir şey daha
anlat hem çocuklara yardım et hem benim
gelişmem sağlar benim adıma devasa bir
kesişim inanılmaz bir
adam çok
farklı dedi ki benden çok var dedim
saygı sunuyorum sana da hakikaten
etkileyici neyse
son aç y Trabzon g trabzon' bir ok
müdürü konu yaptım
[Müzik]
falet
hamiz ek Durum kötü
Tamam ama yardıma ihtiyacı vari Tamam
hocam Ben müdür yardımcısıyla
[Müzik]
anlaştım çalışsınlar diye nasıl
yapıyorsun dedim gece 2'ye kadar ben
kalıyorum 2de müdür yardımcısını
arıyorum karısının yanından kalkıyor
geliyor Sabah 7'ye kadar burada
çocukların başında duruyor Ondan sonra
da ben geliyorum 7'de biz böyle böyle
dedi buradan dedi Fen Lisesi
çıkartacağız okulun tarihinde yok ama
adam diyor ki ben bunu
yapacağım bunların buna ihtiyacı var
diyor çok farklı bir adamdı
[Müzik]
aiz para sonuna kadar Helal olsun ne
istiyorsan Ağla ağ yine Oral
çt Meran finland gittim finland eğitim
sistemlerini öğrenmek için neler yapyor
ylar hangi hareketleri yapıyorlar Bunlar
yapıyorlar dah i gidiyorlar hangi
hareketler ylar
Bun Haa haın son
günü
profesörün karısın koydular Profesör
bize yaptı Biz şöyle eğitiyoruz böle
öğretmen yetiştiriyoruz şunu yapıyoruz
bunu yapıyoruz şunu yapıyoruz bunu
yapıyoruz kaldırdım hocam ded bir şey
soracağım buyun D dedim iyi öğretmen
kimdir adamın gözleri
dolduğun
haı Anadolu'da İstanbul'da binlerce kez
öğretmenlerden duydum Finlandiya'da da
eğitim aynı öğretmen Türkiye'de de
eğitim a öğretmen Tabii ki gelişeceği ki
devam edeceğiz tabii ki daha iyiye doğru
gideceğiz tabii ki daha iyi olacağız bir
önceki Milli Eğitim bakanıyla Bir
yemekte karşılaşmıştık hocam dedim bir
şey söyleyeceğim Evet dedim Bakın
Anadolu'da dedim böyle böyle öğretmenler
var dedim bir şekilde bir
ödüllendirilmesi bir şey yapılması lazım
kuray dedi çok büyük işler var Tamam
dedim ben de ama dedi İstersen ara ben
hemen onlarla konuşayım dedi Olur hocam
dedim hemen aradım Dedim Adana'yı hocam
dedim bakan Bey yanımda seninle konuşmak
istiyor aldı tebrik etti adamı kapattı
hocam ded bir tane Trabzon var Tamam
hocam dedi açtık onu da konuştuk hocam
dedim Bir tane daha var Koray işim var
Peki hocam dedim Benan tane Tan dedim
Öyle güzel oldu şimdi kesişme demek
öğrenme demek öğrenme demek gelişim
demek öğrenmeye devam etmek demek
gelişmeye devam etmek demek yaam sürekli
gelişiyor sürekli değiyor ve doğru
gidiyor bir şeyleri yapmak istiyoruz
orada bir şeyler bizi geliştiriyor bir
şeyler bize daha iyi öğretiyor bir
şeyler bizi daha az öğretiyor bir şeyler
bize daha çok öğretiyor ana mesele nasıl
daha iyi öğreniriz meselesi nasıl daha
iyiye doğru gideriz meselesi nasıl daha
iyi olabiliriz
meselesi Belki biraz Sınırlarımı açtım
uzun süre sürdü Peki çok teşekkür ederim
herkese başarılar dilerim sevgiler
dilim